Today we examine the question why is it
that states, countries, nations, they
rise and they fall. Okay, so let's start
off with an example that you know pretty
well. So this is the waring states
period and at this point in history
there are many powerful states. Okay. So
for example the true, the jao, the way.
Okay. And if at this point in history,
this is about 250 uh B.CE. I asked you
to figure out using game theory, which
state would unite China and become the
first great empire of China. Well, there
are certain metrics that you would use
to figure out which state would win out.
Okay, so obviously you would look at
population.
Okay, who has the largest population?
Okay, so the question of mass.
Second question that you would look at
is maybe resources,
right? And resources, it's basically
just farmland.
So you would look at basically which
areas had the most rivers. Okay? And so
you would be like, okay, well this area
um you know looks very strategic as is
this area as is this area. Okay? And
then you would also look at maybe
technology. So basically which state has
the most scientist, which state has the
most advanced literature, arts and then
from
the these metrics then you could do some
analysis and figure out that maybe true
would come conquer all of China at some
point. Okay. But at no point using any
metrics would you assume that Ting would
conquer China. And there are certain
reasons why. First of all, it's in
mountains, so it's pretty poor. Second
of all, it's it's pretty away far away
from the rivers and trade routes. And
third of all, it's pretty isolated.
Okay, so for you could not possibly
imagine that theQing dynasty would
conquer China. But in fact, it is
theQing that would come and conquer all
of China. And not only that, but if you
look at most of human history, this
pattern repeats itself. If you look at a
region,
the strongest nation does not come out
on top. It's usually the weakest most
marginalized area that will eventually
come and conquer the entire territory
and create an empire. Okay. So clearly
the way that we understand history, it's
problematic. It's wrong. So what I want
to what I want to do is propose to you a
new way to understand how empires come
into being. Okay? And this was actually
first proposed by um a Muslim scholar
historian named Ibin Kudan. Okay.
And he proposed the idea of aasayiah.
And all this word means is basically
cohesion or group solidarity. His theory
is that yes, the people in the margins,
they're poorer, but because they're
poorer, they're more unified.
They are more they focus more on
solidarity, on working together. Whereas
in the rich areas, they become too
individualistic. They become too decent,
too corrupt. And ultimately that's why
it's always these tribes from the
margins that actually [snorts] conquer
the wealthy civilized areas. Okay? And
this is a pattern that repeat repeats
itself throughout human history all the
time. So it's almost like an iron law of
history. So what I want to do is show
you that there actually three metrics
that you can use to measure how dynamic
a society is and how likely it is to
triumph in the end. Okay, these three
metrics are energy,
openness
and cohesion.
Okay, cohesion just follows the idea of
aayiah which is just to say how likely
is it that these people are willing to
work together? Do they see themselves as
a team? Are they willing to sacrifice
themselves for each other? Are they a
family? Okay, so that's the idea of
cohesion.
Openness is a very important concept and
openness just means how willing are you
willing to adapt? How willing are you wi
how much are you willing to accept your
limitations
and be resilient? Okay, so you you can
think of openness as um humility as
resilience. Energy just means that
you're willing to work hard, you're
focused, you have a clear goal and
you're motivated to achieve this goal.
Okay, so these three metrics tell us how
dynamic society is going to be. And
using these three metrics, we can now
better understand why that theQing
dynasty was able to conquer all of
China. Okay, so the idea is that if
you're rich, okay, you're rich, okay,
what happens often is that you have low
energy. And what this means is that the
elite don't want to work anymore. They
rather just exploit
the other people. Okay, the people. And
because the people are being enslaved,
they're too much in debt. They have low
energy as well. For them, it's not
really about building a great nation.
It's not really about doing a great job.
It's just about getting by. Okay? So,
and then the idea of openness is that
[snorts] the elite become extremely
corrupt. They become very insulated.
They become very arrogant. And so they
refuse to admit that they're wrong. And
as a result, society becomes snack
stagnant. It doesn't really improve. And
the idea of cohesion is that because of
wealth inequality, because of
corruption, people are much more
individualized, people are much more
animized. Okay? And this allows for a uh
new group to come in and conquer
everyone.
Okay? Does that make sense, guys? All
right. So, um I'm going to use sorry
I'm going to use actually
um another example. Okay,
an example is
the Greek city states. And remember the
Greek city states, it's really the
height of human civilization. They gave
us Homer, Plato, Fidities, uh Sophocles.
Okay, just basically the basis for all
of western civilization. Now what's
interesting is that for most of the of
their history, the Greek city states and
these are basically like this small
small cities. Okay, there are thousand
of them and and on average they're about
a thousand people each. There are some
big city states like Athens but even
Athens is not that big. So at its height
Athens had about 50,000 people. Okay, so
these city states like Athens, thieves,
um, Sparta, okay, these are the major
ones and there are other Korean argos,
they're always in competition with each
other, very much like the Chinese waring
states as well. And again, if we look at
the year 500 BCE,
you would think that maybe Athens or
Sparta would emerge as the grand unifier
of the Greek city states. And in fact,
what happened was that Athens did become
an empire. But then the other Greek the
other Greek city states start to attack
Athens and Athens declined over time.
Okay? And the advantage that Athens had
over everyone else was just tremendous.
First of all, Athens had the greatest
navy. Okay, as you can see, uh the AGN
is primarily about who controls the
seas. So a so was able to control the
trade routes in the um Aian. Therefore,
it's the wealthiest city state. It have
the greatest population, has the most
innovation. It has the most strategic
location. It has most most wealth. So,
you would just assume that Athens would
come to conquer all the Greedy states.
But in fact, it was the Macedonians,
okay, who came in and conquered all the
city states. And at this time in
history, you couldn't possibly imagine
that because the Macedonians were poor.
They were isolated. They were not all
cultured. They were univilized. Okay.
But again, they had energy, openness,
and cohesion. And that allowed them to
conquer the citystates. What's most
what's amazing is that even after this
area was unified, okay, the Maconians
would then do the impossible and go over
and conquer the great Persian Empire,
the first great empire in human history.
It was huge. It was Egypt, Anatolia,
Mesopotamia, the Zagos malt mountains,
Persia. It was everywhere. And in a very
quick amount of time, the Macedonians
under the Great, they sailed across the
Aian. landed a small fort and then very
quickly in about 10 years time conquered
the entire Persian Empire. And at this
point in history is you would think that
the Persian Empire sorry you would think
that the new national empire would be
invincible but then what happened a few
decades later is the rise of the Romans.
Who are the Romans? Well, at this time
in history, we don't know who they are.
Okay.
Um
uh Rome is probably here somewhere.
Okay. But as you can see, the entire
Italian peninsula is being colonized by
the Greeks. And then the Romans, who
are, you know, these poor backward
tribal people, eventually over time they
will conquer the entire Italian
peninsula and they're going to go and
conquer
the Greek u mainland and then go go
south to conquer uh Carthage as well and
they will create the Roman Empire. Okay,
so this is a pattern that repeats itself
throughout human history.
The empire becomes corrupt, lazy,
arrogant. This and this gives
opportunity for a troubled people,
whether it's a Macedonians, whether it's
aqing, whether it's a Romans to come and
conquer all of them. Okay. But now the
question then is okay if that's true.
Um and so let's look at more examples,
okay, of this.
Let's look at the Aztecs. And the Aztecs
is even a more stark example. So this is
this is about the 16th century 15th
century. Okay, as you can see um the
Mexican peninsula it's it is
divided into
different waring city states. Okay, very
similar situation to the Greek city
states and the Chinese city states. Then
what's happen is the Aztecs we are going
to come in from the north. Okay. And the
Aztecs are
um a poor tribe that's starving. Okay.
So, they're basically from uh North
America. They come in because they're
looking for food and they're warrior
people. So, they're hired by other city
states to fight for them. Eventually,
they become too powerful. So, they
become isolated onto a marsh. Okay? And
this marsh, it's poor. And everyone just
put them just assumed that they would
starve to death in this marsh. What's
amazing is that as a people they became
very creative and they turn this marsh
into farmland and over time they will
slowly come to conquer everyone. Okay.
And they establish the Aztec Empire
which rules over millions and millions.
And then what happens which is one of
the greatest mysteries in human history
is you have another group of people
called the concquisidors
from Spain and there's only about 500 of
them okay
arriving about the year 195 1519 they
come in and in like a very short amount
of time they conquer the entire Aztec
Empire and Spain comes to rule basically
all of South and Latin America. Okay. So
even though yes we have a formula in
place whichever group has the most
energy whichever group is the most open
the most cohesive will conquer the other
groups it still doesn't explain to us
how this happened how this guy uh
Hernandez with 500 conquisttors was able
to come in and conquer a land
uh of millions and millions. Okay. Now,
there are historical explanations
including of course disease.
Uh people from Spain had diseases and
the Aztecs were not did not have the
immune system to counter uh these these
diseases. Another explanation is um the
Aztecs believed that these conquesters
were gods and that's why they
surrendered very quickly. Another
explanation is that the conquesttors had
allies, local allies that were pissed
off at the Aztecs. But again,
these explanations, they sound okay.
They sound like they work, but they
don't actually give us the full picture
of what really happened. And in game
theory, what we're really trying to
figure out is what happened exactly.
Okay, it's a game. How are the players
um playing the game? What are their
motivations? What are their incentives?
Okay, does it make sense? Okay, that's
that's what we're trying to figure out
what actually happened in this instance.
[snorts]
Uh I want to look at one more example
before we look into the theory of game
in in game theory. Okay, this is one of
the early civilizations in human
history. Okay, in fact um it's
considered the first great civilization
of human history. It is the Samrians.
And what happened was that um you look
at a world map. Okay, this is a world
map, right? Mesopotamia is a center of
the world because you want to access the
rest of the world, you have to go
through Mesopotamia. And if you look at
Mesopotamia, the center of Mesopotenia
is a place called Uric. Okay, sorry. U
okay, [snorts]
which is here. Okay, as you can see,
Uric is the meeting place of the
Euphrates and the Tigris. And if you
look at this, the URI uh allows you to
access uh the Persian Gulf, which gives
you access to India, [clears throat]
okay? Or we call the IBC, the Indis
Valley civilization. And then um and
then you allow and then traders are able
to take the goods and cross to Egypt,
okay? And then you're able to go north
to Anatolia.
So why did Europe become the first great
world city? Because it was a center of
all global trade. So different people
came together into the city in order to
establish a trading post. Okay. And over
time it grew and it grew and grew
because it was very wealthy.
Okay. And over time um it colonies
elsewhere. Okay. So it's up colonies in
other places. And then eventually these
different city states came into conflict
with with with each other which is the
same process as what happened with the
Chinese waring states as well as the
Greek city states. And you would assume
that one of these city states would
conquer the rest. But in fact again it
was these tribal mercenaries
uh from an isolated region called the
Acadians. The Aadians who would come and
conquer everyone else. Okay. and the
Acadians.
Okay. And after after they they built
the first empire, okay, then what
happened is that other people come over
and conquer them as well. And then you
had people from the Zagos mountains, the
Persians basically come in and unify the
entire area and create the Persian
Empire. All right. So this is a pattern
that emerges throughout human history.
It's a pretty consistent pattern. Okay,
we have theories as to why this is
happening. Yes, we do know that groups
that are energetic, open, and cohesive
are will triumph over other groups.
But the idea of game theory is to figure
out exactly what happened. Okay. So,
let's go over exactly what happened. And
I I will show you that what's happening
is that as nations rise and fall, the
games they play changes.
Okay? Does that make sense?
The game changes and therefore their
motivations, their incentives, their
strategies change over time. All right.
Okay. So, um are are we clear about the
history here? All right. Okay.
All right.
So, in the beginning, okay, game theory
game.
Okay. Rise.
Okay.
In the beginning, you as a people need
to come together and build a land in
which you can all prosper or at least
have food to eat. Okay? Therefore the
game is cooperation
and the mechanism cooperation actually
religion.
So in this first game okay what you're
trying to do is you're trying to create
a dynamic religion that motivates people
to be energetic to give them reason to
work really hard. Okay. And the people
who are best able to articulate this
religion become the elite. Okay. And
this includes poets and priests.
All right, poets and priests.
And at this point in history, it's
basically a startup. Okay, everyone's
enthusiastic. Everyone's working hard.
Everyone feels as though they're making
a positive contribution to the world.
But over time, what happens is that the
elite, okay,
become
hereditary. The game becomes how do I
the elite pass on my privileges to my
children? Okay. And and the way they do
that is by changing the religion.
Okay. The religion now becomes
almost like a bureaucracy.
So in the first game, the religion is
about energy. It's about creativity.
It's about working together. Okay. But
then in the second iteration, the the
religion becomes like a bureaucracy
which is like you must follow the rules
of the game. Okay. The rules of the game
are set. There's a hierarchy and you
must obey this hierarchy.
Okay. [snorts] Now then what happens is
a process called elite overp production.
Okay, the idea of late over production
is that yes, these privileges are being
passed on to the children, but now over
time they have there are too many
children. And so what happens is that
society breaks up into different
factions. Okay? And usually what happens
is that these factions are divided
according to the princes. Okay? So if
there are four princes, okay, who are
about to inherit the throne, there are
four different factions that support
them.
That does that does not mean the prince
is the leader of the faction. It just
means that the prince is the symbol of a
faction. Okay. All right. And at this
time in history, the way that they
reduce the conflict is is the losing
factions. What what they do is they move
away. Okay? They're exile. Okay? And
then they have to set up
a new colony.
And this is a process that continues
where the losers of the game are forced
into exile
until there's no more place to colonize.
Okay? And now you have the waring states
period. Okay? The waring states period.
And in fact, what's interesting is that
the waring states period
is a time of maximum creativity
for a civilization. Why? is the idea of
open cooperative
competition.
Okay. So, back to theQing, back to the
Greeks,
uh the um Samrians, there are different
colonies, okay? And they're all
competing against each other.
And so, you need to be open and
innovative if if you're triumph, okay?
At the same time, they're trading with
each other. So they're sharing best
practices. They're sharing innovations
with each other. Okay? So this leads to
the idea of open competition, which
again marks the height of the
civilization. So guess what guys,
China's been around for 5,000 years, but
most of the invasions happened when? It
happened during the waring states
period. 100 years when we had k
confusious mons uh la
it's basically everyone. Okay. All
right. And and [clears throat] if you
just look at um other civilizations,
it's the same for other civilizations as
well where if you look at the Greeks um
during the classical period, they
basically created everything that
becomes the foundation for western
civilization. Okay, does that make
sense? All right. Now what's interesting
is what happens next.
Eventually what happens is these city
states figure out that you know what yes
the game is we compete against each
other but we can also choose to work
together. Okay. How do you work
together? By intermarriage. Okay
intermarriage.
And the idea of intermarriage creates
the idea of equilibrium.
And at this point in history warfare
becomes organized
warfare.
Okay. So remember uh before warfare was
about innovation but now when these
elites from different city states when
they intermar with each other okay they
have a new equilibrium. So they are
above the above the state now. Okay.
Does it make sense guys? All right. So
now when they fight, it's not really
about fighting each other. It's about
reducing their population to maintain
control.
Okay? It's a way to resolve the elite o
over production issue. We have too many
people struggling for too many status
positions. And the way you do that is
through population control. Okay? So
warfare becomes a mechanism of
population
control.
All right? So even though these
city states are still in theory
competing against each other they
essentially now have reach an
equilibrium and equilibrium a no for
equilibrium is basically they have
empire.
Okay.
All right. So now the game changes.
Before during the war states period, it
was a game to see which state would be
the best, the most innovative, and
that's why you invite people who um
could contribute the most to your city
state. Okay, that's that's why you were
meritocracy. You only pro promoted the
best and the brightest. Once you reach
an equilibrium, you don't have to do
that. Okay, all you have to do is just
maintain the status quo. And so what
happens is you create this rigid
hierarchy.
And what matters is who reaches the top
office hierarchy. And as a result, you
create court politics, right? Court
politics
or factional struggle factions.
Okay? Does it make sense, guys? All
right. So if you look at any court
politics,
the faction that triumphs is the one
that's able to solve three problems.
Okay, three problems.
These three problems are
secrecy,
trust,
and coordination.
Remember,
in theory,
everyone has to obey the bureaucracy,
right? [snorts] But if you just play by
the rules of the game, you're going to
lose. So, what you want to do is you
want to cheat in the game. The way But
if you want to cheat in the game, you
have to do so secretly. Okay? You have
to do secretly. But if you do so
secretly, that creates a problem of like
how do you trust each other? If you
don't if you and if you if you're doing
it all in secret, the problem is like
how do you coordinate? How do you move
together, right? Because you you can't
have meetings where you take notes
because if you're discovered, you'll all
be executed by the other factions. Okay?
So, historically, the way we resolve
this issue is through the idea of secret
societies.
[snorts]
Okay. So, um let's figure out how secret
societies work. And this is true for
China. This is true for the Greeks. This
is true for the Aztecs. This is true for
everyone. Okay. But like there's certain
um aspects of secret societies. Okay.
The first is idea of secrecy. Okay. How
do you do that? Well, you do that
through the idea of a hierarchy.
Okay. Hierarchy
or compment comprementalization.
And so there are different so within
single societies there's a hierarchy as
well where only have people at the very
top know what's going on and if you want
to join you initiate it but you have put
at the bottom okay and slowly you climb
the ladder okay and this is to maintain
secrecy trust how do you get people to
trust each other well you get people to
trust each other through the idea of
transgression
okay
so if we cheat on attached together we
are much more likely to trust each
other. Doesn't make sense because if
you're caught you you you all get
punished. Okay. So by bringing the law
together we can trust each other. Okay.
And the most basic type of um
transgression is the idea of ritual
sacrifice.
Okay. And the idea of ritual sacrifice
is you basically decide to go kill
someone together. Okay. you capture that
person then for some um uh ritual you
then kill that person. Okay, doesn't
make sense and then to solve the problem
of coordination you have the idea of
esquetology.
Esquetology is just mythology. All
right, like why are you guys doing what
you're doing? Okay. And the answer often
is because we're trying to serve a
higher god that wants to conquer the
world and we are his servants in this
quest to conquer the world and end the
world to make it a paradise. Okay. So
different suicides have different
esquetologies but the system is the
same.
Okay. Doesn't make sense. Okay. And what
happens is and this is like really
important guys.
Every faction has to form their own
secret society. And now the game of
empire becomes one of a struggle between
different secret societies. Does it make
sense? Meaning what? Meaning you don't
care what happens to the empire. You
don't care about the enemies of the
empire. All you care about that you your
team emerges on top of the game. Okay?
And so what does that mean? It means
that you become
sorry
insular.
All right.
Okay. You become insular. You also
become corrupt.
Okay. Because you need resources to play
this game. So what you do is you steal
from the people. Okay? It's all it's all
about trying to steal as much as you can
in order to feed your faction. You
become insular. you become corrupt.
Okay. Um and then divided.
Okay. Do you understand? This is what
happens because of different factions
within the empire or the equilibrium.
They become insular, they become corrupt
and they become
uh divided. Okay. which is why
they ultimately lose to these struggle
factions because the opposite of insular
of course is open. The the um the
opposite of corrupt is energetic
and the opposite of divided is of course
cohesive cohesion. Okay.
Okay. Now we understand why ultimately
the borderlands the tribes and
borderlands are able to conquer
the empire or the equilibrium. Okay,
does that make sense, guys? All right,
but there's actually more to this. Okay,
the and so what happens is that you have
the different factions,
okay? Societies fighting against each
other. And again, from their
perspective, all they care about is
winning against the other factions. So
what do they do? What they do is they
invite
other foreigners to come help them. Hey,
do you understand?
Okay. So, these are what are called
mercenaries.
[snorts]
All right. And these mercenaries come
into them and their leadership is
absorbed into the societies through um
esquetology, through transgression,
through hierarchy. Okay. All right.
So this is what happens. These
mercenaries actually invited in. Okay.
And and and like but there's always
contact. Okay. kind of through trade
banditry
mercenary.
Okay, doesn't make sense because these
people these in the regions they're so
poor they'll do anything to survive. So
they'll trade of you but they also steal
from you and they also come and fight
for you. Okay. What's important is that
through trade they're becoming
wealthier.
Through benetry they're becoming
wealthier as well. And by become by
working as your mercenaries they're de
they are learning your best technology,
your best fighting skills, your best
weapons. Okay.
Right. And then what happens is that the
mercenaries eventually take over. Okay.
At first they merge, but then the
mercenaries just kill everyone and then
take over.
And that's how what happens. That's why
theQing were able to conquer the waring
states. Okay? They don't teach you this
in history class, but according to game
theory, what happened was that different
factions of these different states
actually inviting
just basically conquered one by one by
one. Does that make sense? Same thing
with the Macedonians, right? The master
came in and helped one city state. Then
they call one city state and move on to
the next. Okay. But it was always a
certain part of that city state, a
certain faction of that city state which
invite the mark is in the first place.
Okay?
Doesn't make sense.
And this is a pattern that repeats
itself throughout
human history.
Okay? So if you want to know what's
going to happen today, what's going to
happen tomorrow, just figure out which
areas of the world are the most
energetic, most open, and most cohesive,
and then figure out which empires are
the most corrupt, most insular, and the
most divided. Okay? And then you'll
figure out who will conquer who. All
right?
Does that make sense, guys? All right?
So, I'm going to give you two more
examples to better illustrate how this
works. All right? So when I was in high
school in Canada, we played a game
called the world game.
And in this game, it's very simple.
Okay, you're you're put into a team of
maybe four or five players. Okay. And
then each team is assigned a country
like maybe USA,
Britain,
uh India,
Pakistan, Japan
and then each team is given an envelope.
Okay. And then with within this envelope
you're given certain resources. Okay. So
basically, you know, paper,
scissors,
ruler. Okay. And then there's there's an
or organization called the World Bank.
And what you're trying to do is you're
trying to become the wealthiest country
in the world. The way you do that is you
take your resources and you turn it into
commodities that the World Bank buys
from you. Okay? Okay, so maybe like
triangles and circles and squares. Okay,
but to create these commodities, you
need resources, right? You need
scissors, you need rulers, you need
paper, you need glue,
okay, but different countries will have
different resource resources. So United
States has everything. Okay.
And Pakistan is interesting because
Pakistan usually gets nothing.
Okay. There are no resources.
But you're allowed to trade with each
other, right? Okay. You're allowed to
trade with each other. [snorts]
Okay. So, even though you have nothing,
you can go to United States and beg and
say, "Oh, oh, can I please borrow your
ruler for for today?" Okay. You go to
Britain says, "Hey, can I can I borrow
your paper for today?" Okay? Or, "Hey,
I'll come work for you for free." Right?
You can trade. And so you play this for
for one day and it's really interesting
what happens. Okay, usually what happen
I'm not saying all the time but I've
seen this happen a lot. At the end of
the day you you look at who are the
wealthiest countries in the world. What
happens is well the United States
becomes number one. Okay. Why? Because
United States just has everything in the
world. It is the wealthiest country in
the world. It has too much resources.
Okay. But number two is interesting. You
would think it would be Japan and
Britain, but it's actually Pakistan,
okay? The country that starts out with
nothing at all. Why? Because they're
forced to be the most energetic, the
most open, and most cohesive. Team
members have to go and beg to work for
free. Okay? Other team members go and
lie and cheat and steal. Okay? They're
forced to be resourceful and creative.
Okay? the world game. And that's how the
world works, guys. Just because you have
the most resources, just because you
have the most people does not mean
you'll win the game at the end. What
matters is how energetic your people
are, how open they are, how resourceful
they are. That's what matters.
Okay? And often they are open,
energetic, and cohesive because they're
poor.
All right? It's that simple. Pakistan
has nothing. So they're they're forced
to be creative. Poverty leads to
creativity.
Okay.
Another thing this is that if I were to
surmise the future, I would say right
now in in East Asia, I would think that
North Korea has a better future than
China.
Okay? Just based on history. And it
would be like that's impossible. North
Korea can feed its own people. Well, I
understand that. But if you know game
theory, okay, and you understand the
principles that we've learned today,
then you're forced to conclude that in
East Asia, North Korea has a better
future than China because ultimately
it's about how open, energetic, and
cohesive the people are as opposed to
how rich and powerful you are. Okay,
does that make sense? I will also point
out another example.
Okay. [snorts] So before teaching in
high school, I was teaching uh teachers
how to teach STEM. Okay. State STEM
education.
And I usually run two-day workshops.
And what I would do is I go into a
school and I divide the faculty, the
teachers into teams, okay? Like teams of
like four or five. There'd be like 10
teams. Okay? There'd be a lot of
teachers. And the way I teach is I would
give them an assignment and I I I would
give them resources and I and it would
be a competition. Okay, so for example,
let's look at which team can build the
fastest car. Okay, toy car. Let's look
at let's look at which team can build um
the best airplane. Uh let's look at
which team can build a catapult. Okay,
so so I would give them some resources.
I give them the assignment and then they
would work on a whole day. Okay. Now,
what's interesting is at the end of the
first day, you would have
I would rank the teams. Okay.
And then number two, and then day two,
we would start the competition again
with a new assignment.
On day two, which team would finish
first? Do you guys know?
So after day one all 10 teams are ranked
according to their success. Okay. So
team one has the best 10 team team 10
has the worst. What happened the second
day? Can you guys guess?
>> I think team 10 wins.
>> Yeah. Okay. According to game theory,
what happens is team 10 wins. And this
this exactly what happens. The results
are reversed. Okay. number 10 shoots up
to number one and then number one falls
all the way down.
This is what happens a lot. It's it's
actually common sense if you think about
it, right? If you're the best student in
the school, you never have to reflect.
You never have to like think about how
to improve because you're always number
one. So you become arrogant. You become
complacent. So after you graduate from
school, what happens? You can't find any
work because people find you too
arrogant. You refuse to learn. You want
to be the boss. You want people to just
listen to you. Okay. But if you're the
worst student in a school, you're used
to being laughed at. You're used to um
constantly adapting. Okay? So when you
go into the workplace,
you are much more likely to
uh learn. You're much more likely to
focus on relationships.
Okay? So in China China, there's a joke,
right? In school, there are two people
that everyone hates. Okay? the best
student and the worst student. Why do
you hate the best student? Because the
best student is going to graduate and
come back as your principal one day. Why
do you hate the worst student? Because
he's going to graduate and come back and
give you a lecture on how to become
rich.
Okay? That's why in China, everyone
hates the best student and the worst
student. And these are and these are two
students who will probably be the most
successful. Okay? Especially the worst
student because the worst student,
regardless of all his problems, he's
openminded. He's willing to work hard
and he's willing to help build teams and
make make sacrifices so that others
become his friend. Okay. Right. Um uh
yeah we have a question.
Um so like for example for this case in
day two the team 10 becomes the first
one and the first team becomes the last
but will the like will the previously
the first team been forced to be open
and to be energetic and then be number
one again on the third day. That is a
great question. Thank you for asking it.
Okay so in my experience this is what
happens. Okay.
What happens is that
if what happens if we keep on going
right? What happens in day three
day team team day
day three day four. Okay this this this
what happens. Team one
really screws up on day two, right? They
finish first in day one. Day two, they
screw up.
Day three and day four, they continue to
screw up. Why? Because they don't know
what they did wrong and they refuse
to
um reflect. Do you understand? Okay. So,
we see this in history where an empire
once it rises, it falls. It never comes
back. It never comes back. Do you
understand? It never rise up up again.
Now, it's possible that new people come
in and use the name of the empire, okay?
But it's not the same people anymore.
It's a different team. So, that's a
danger of being number one.
Once you're number one,
you become so arrogant that it's that
impossible for you to be humble again.
Okay.
Um, team two, we go down. Okay. So it's
very unlikely that you have a system
where okay uh team one they fall but
then they reflect and become number one
again. Okay. It doesn't work that way.
When societies fall they just die off.
Okay. It's possible a new group comes
and pretends to be them but they're
actually a different people. And and
that's just way that humans work.
Okay. Does that make sense? Yes.
>> Okay.
Yep.
So on the third day, the team 10 will
become the second last group because
they fall and the n the group nine will
be the first one. Is that the cycle that
will go on?
>> Um yeah. So I' I've never run a day
three so I can't say for sure. Okay. But
but that that's what should happen.
Okay.
All right, that's what should happen
where yes, team 10 will fall off and a
new team will come into place. Okay. All
right. And if you look at history,
that's just the way it is. Again, we
don't have an example of where an empire
fell but then the people decide to like
change their um their uh mentality and
then they become the best again. Okay.
So, in the future, if you if we apply
this theory, there should be three
countries that will emerge as great
empires in our history. Okay,
Germany. Why? Because they lost World
War I and lost World War II. Does that
make sense, guys? They were never an
empire. They were never a world empire.
So, Germany, according to this theory,
will one day come to rule the world or
at least Europe and Asia. Okay? And if
you if you actually look at their
history, what happened in World War I,
World War II, they lost millions of
people. Okay? So, Germany will will be
one day a great empire. I'm pretty sure
of it actually. And then there's another
country that would be a great empire and
that is
Japan because Japan lost World War II.
They were never a great empire. So Japan
should come to dominate East Asia
according his theory. Remember the
Americans dropped two nukes on Japan,
right? And also look at World War II,
the Americans destroyed Japan with
firebombing. They the Americans killed
more fire bombing than actually did with
the nukes. Okay? But Japan was
destroyed. It was humiliated. And and
now you go to Japan, you can see how
energetic people are, right? You can see
how open they are. And you can see how
cohesive they are.
You understand?
Because Japan was destroyed in World War
II. It's something that force them to
reflect as a people and now they want
vengeance basically. All right. And the
last country of course is Israel, right?
Because Israel, the people in Israel
believe that for thousands of years they
were persecuted by other people. Okay.
So these are three great empires that we
we will move towards in our history.
Germans, Japan uh uh Japanese and the
Israelis. Okay. Does that make sense?
>> Mhm.
>> All right. The Americans are done.
>> How about China?
>> Done. Okay. [snorts]
All right. [clears throat]
Look, look guys, guys. I mean like like
this is all just a theory, okay? But all
I'm saying is look around you and ask
yourself, are the people here
open-minded? Are they willing to learn
from their mistakes? Do they ever say
I'm wrong?
Are people energetic? Do do they take
their work very seriously? If I give
people an assignment, will they work
really hard to make sure it's done well?
Do people feel as though they're all
part of one big group? Are are they
willing to make sacrifices for each
other?
Okay, Japan is. Okay, that's all I'm
saying. and maybe even the North Koreans
are. All right, does that make sense,
guys? And again, it's all just a theory.
All right, I I'm just proposing to you a
theory of how to understand the world,
but what's actually going to happen, I
can't actually tell you, right? But
according to this theory, um Germany and
Japan and Israel will be the three great
nations.
Any more questions, guys?
>> Yeah. C can you can you
>> Oh, yeah. But like for example the uh
Japan that it did didn't have that much
sources. So how could they succeed?
[laughter]
>> I I keep on telling you guys you don't
need resources. You can cheat, you can
steal, you can beg. All right.
Okay. Does that make sense?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Like like if you just go back to
the world game, um whichever team starts
off with the least resources are often
the most creative. Okay. When I mean
creative, they'll just like go and like
lie to people. Says, you know, like I'll
come work to you for free, but then
you'll steal some some resources
yourself. Okay. All right. Because they
have actually no choice in the matter,
right? Uh yeah. Yeah. So I have a little
questions like uh you you say that those
who are poorest and like in the most
dangerous positions always have the most
energy and cohesions to succeed. But I I
think eventually
>> All right. So so so so okay. Let me be
precise. Okay. Yeah.
>> Just because you're poor does not mean
you're open, energetic, and cohesive.
Okay. Does not mean that.
>> But if you want to go from being poor to
becoming rich, you have to be open,
energetic, and cohesive. Does that make
sense?
>> Yeah. So
>> because in Africa, they're poor, but
doesn't mean they're open, energetic,
and cohesive.
>> Yeah. So, so my question is like after
they become successful and they are
eventually re rich, I think like like
all society they may fall as like be
when they reach the their their their
higher state, right?
>> Yes.
>> Yeah. And so my question is uh like you
you say that like the J Japan or Germany
will eventually become the like the
leader of the of the of their like
>> regions
>> regions but like I I understand that
after World War II the Japan and German
really develop very fast but like now
they are all wealthy societies and also
[snorts] They're young the youngesters
the young the the new like people in
their country forget about the war and
they well when they born they born in
the wealthy and like happy happy
societies. So how can you make sure that
the the society those society will
continue to cohesions and developed but
not like just to fail like other rich
societies.
>> Okay, you know that's a great question.
That's a great point. Okay, you're
absolutely right because after World War
[snorts] II uh Japan and Germany become
very wealthy. So if they become very
wealthy then in theory shouldn't they
become also corrupt, insular and
arrogant? And the answer is no. Okay?
And there's good reason why. Because
ultimately power means that you're able
to impose your game on other people.
You're able to make other people play
your game and therefore you're able to
extract rent from other people. Okay?
And that's what and that's what these
secret sides are fighting for. They're
fighting for power. Who becomes the game
master. The problem with Japan and
Germany is yes became very wealthy but
the game master was America.
And ultimately America decided that
their money belongs to me. Okay. So an
example of this is something called the
plastic courts. Okay. Plac courts.
[snorts]
Basically the plastic court just meant
that um Japan was was becoming too
wealthy. America got very annoyed. So
America said to Japan I want you to
destroy your economy. And Japan's like
how? America says just say says I want
you to spend too much money. I want you
people to stop saving money and start
spending money. Go overseas and buy
whatever crap you want. Okay? [snorts]
Do you understand? So in theory it
seemed as though Japan got rich but
Japan got rich but it never had any
power. It it it could not be a sovereign
nation. Okay. Power means that you're
able to impose your will on other
people. Same with Germany where yes
Germany became very wealthy but all that
money went where? It went to America
right? Same with Japan. Japan all that
money went to America. H how? Because
they were forced to buy US treasury
bonds.
Okay. And then America could do stuff to
you. For example, um America could force
Japan to sign a plastic cord and force
Japan to destroy its own economy. And
America could also destroy Germany's
pipeline, North Street. And there's
nothing Germany can do about it. Okay?
In fact, the German economy has been
destroyed right now because Germany is a
vassal state to America.
So when um Russia invaded Ukraine,
America just basically said to Germany,
you can no longer do business deals with
Russia. But before Germany required
Russian oil and energy to fuel its
economy. Okay. America also said to
Germany, you can you can no longer trade
with China. But before most of uh German
car exports were going to China, right?
>> Yeah. And because
Germany was forced out of the China
market, China was able to develop its
own manufacturing industry.
>> Okay. Does that make sense?
>> Yeah.
>> So it seems as though Germany and Japan
become very wealthy. They were not. They
they were just vast states to America.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Does that make sense?
>> Yeah. So I have a
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Uh so like you said
that only those society who are very
poor but they want to they have the
ability to co to to cohisions and be
energetic and they can they can like
eventually become the ruler of the
regions. But what decide a society or a
poor society to become energetic
cohesions or not? Like why Japan or
German uh have that energy but like
those other countries that may also like
be defeated on in the war or is very
poor uh cannot.
>> Yeah, that's a great question. Yeah. So
the answer the obvious answer is a
leader. Okay. So you look at the
Mongols, right? the Mongols uh before
the emergence of of gang of Khan, the
Mongols were almost like a vassal state,
right? Because the Mongols were divided,
they were poor,
um they they were willing to do whatever
it took to survive. And so um they
became mercenaries to the Song, they
became mercenaries to other groups as
well. Okay. But then emerg to unify
everyone. And once he was able to unify
everyone, the Mongols were very quickly
able to destroy everyone else. Okay? So
it's usually a great leader. But leader
doesn't necessarily mean a general. It
could also mean a poet,
right? So someone like Homer or a great
thinker to give you a new religion.
Okay? So for example, the person had
someone called Zorah
which who we studied last semester.
Okay? Even Jesus. Okay? But it's someone
to come in to say that we are a people
and it could be a poet, it could be um a
general, [snorts] it could be a um
prophet, a priest, doesn't matter. Okay.
But that one person
then unifies the imagination of everyone
into one cohesive group.
>> Okay. Does that make sense?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. But that's a great question. Thank
you. Okay. And that's why some certain
groups uh are able to um cohhere
together and other groups are not
because one um person is able to merge
and you know that's why okay we'll talk
about this later on but that's why the
world is the way it is. Why do we have
organizations like the United Nations?
Why do we have international development
aid? The goal guys is to identify the
possibility
of a leader emerging and make sure he
does not emerge. You understand?
Okay. If you left Africa alone, Africa
will be a lot better. But because you
have all these schools, all these NOS's,
all these organizations in Africa, what
they're really doing is ensuring that
Africa is in a continuous state of
development. Okay? If you just left them
alone, they might starve. But at the
same time, a great deal might emerge to
unite all of them.
You understand? Okay. But we'll talk
about this next class. How the American
Empire controls the world. [snorts]